las Fuertes lluvias en Brasil dejan a su
paso devastación en Sao Joao Batista en
el estado Santa Catarina el 95% del
municipio quedó afectado viviendas
vehículos y casas quedaron dañadas lo
mismo ocurrió en otras 30 ciudades del
estado
el agua llegó hasta este tejado de aquí
yo estaba al otro lado de la calle en la
casa de mi vecino y vi como el agua
llegaba hasta la puerta había algunas
cosas que había puesto encima de mi
cocina pero la alacena se vino abajo con
todo batidora licuadora todo se fue al
suelo
y baby los habitantes desesperados andan
por las calles con sus enseres mojados
una de las afectadas tuvo suerte en
comparación con otras personas que lo
perdieron todo
hubo gente que pasó peor ahora pasó un
señor de edad y su casa quedó destruida
sin duda hay otros que tuvieron peores
estragos
la crecida de las aguas fue de 1,6
metros el equipo de protección civil
declaró el estado de emergencia mientras
el gobierno local creó un comité de
crisis muchos se refugiaron en un
albergue mientras están a la espera de
que la crisis pase y puedan volver a sus
casas con lo poco que les queda tras La
tempestad viene la calma pero también la
incertidumbre que trae consigo la
tragedia